hey clatter fans Bohemian Rhapsody is
out in theaters this weekend the film
traces the meteoric rise of Freddie
Mercury and queen through their iconic
songs and revolutionary sound and
culminates with the legendary set at
1985 s Live Aid which I was old enough
to have seen on TV my god the film and
Ronny Malik's transcendent performance
has gotten some high praise from us here
at Collider and so it motivated us to
look back through the history of film
and countdown our top 5 music biopics
there been quite a few over the years
ranging from Elvis Presley to Tina
Turner to Sid Vicious to Richy balance
to Ian Curtis tank Williams to Beethoven
and everything in between
so it was a Killer Queen cutting this
list down to just five all right sit
back in your assigned seat with your
concert shirt on and your beverage in
hand and get ready to rock out to this
list coming in at number five is Oliver
Stone's 1991 biopic on the doors titled
The Doors well that's an easy one to
remember the film stars Val Kilmer as
Jim Morrison and what may be the
greatest performance of his career he
brings Morris into life so vividly that
you as the viewer feel that you are
watching the reincarnation of Morrison
and not just an actor performing the
role the film chronicles the coming
together of the doors and their rise in
the Southern California rock scene
during the late 60s and early 70s as
they achieved their success Morrison's
experiential personality threatens to
destroy the group on and off the stage
as they run afoul of their promoters
their fans and the law stone captures
why they were such a unique fan in the
rock galaxy with some great concert
scenes a special note is the not to
touch the earth scene where stone
infuses the Native American influences
of Morrison and shamanic atmosphere that
Morrison The Doors created in their
performances it's one not to be missed
the film also stars Kyle MacLachlan as
Ray Manzarek Frank Whaley as Robby
Krieger and Kevin Dillon as John
Densmore the number for a movie on our
list is a legendary group out of
Southern California as well but for
vastly different reasons 2015's Straight
Outta Compton from director F gary Gray
chronicles the formation of NWA the
gangster rap pioneers from the early 90s
the group's membership includes do see
DJ yella MC Ren and three MCS who will
go on to achieve global fame and dr. Dre
Ice Cube and eazy-e Gray does not shy
away from highlighting the past of the
group members but he also showcases the
very real societal pressures
motivated the greatest music he includes
some pulsating concert scenes as well
that bring the best of nwaz music to
life but he also finds time to highlight
the smaller more personal moments
between the members that solidified them
as a family it's so well done that when
the divisions start to show within the
group that will eventually doom them you
can't help but feel like desperate hope
for them to work it out before the
powerful loss that comes at the end
Corey Hawkins stars as dr. Dre O'Shea
Jackson jr. as Ice Cube
who is his real-life dad Jason Mitchell
is easy and Paul Giamatti as their
allegedly duplicitous manager Jerry
Heller NWA was one step ahead of the rap
game as the genre was moving away from
the hand-waving crowd leaders of the 80s
to the more brutally honest and socially
conscious music that was catching the
attention of the pop culture zeitgeist
and great perfectly captures it here ray
NAB's our number three spot Jamie Foxx's
transformation into Ray Charles is
nothing short of revelatory and he won
the Best Actor in 2004 for his
performance Taylor Hackford who was also
nominated for Best Director directs this
biopic that chronicles Charles's life
from a child who slowly goes blind at
the age of seven in the deep south to
the worldwide sensation he becomes
thanks to his unique approach to rhythm
and blues music along the way we see
Charles deal with a myriad of issues as
he climbs the ladder of Fame including
racism mistreatment from bam mates
because of his blindness anger within
his own community for using gospel music
as the foundation for his R&B sound and
resistance from music executives to take
charge of the direction of his career
but what really sets this biopic apart
is the gutsiness to not show an
altogether flattering portrait of the
man as he pursues his musical dreams
Hackford and Fox show us Charles's drug
addiction in all its sadness and
ugliness they also show us his
womanizing ways and how both of these
issues threatened to destroy his
marriage and his family but overall the
film is a portrait of a self-made man
who overcame his blindness to find his
unique sound through trial and error and
establish himself as a legend in the
world of music our penultimate film is
the 1984 Oscar winner for Best Picture
dais the film directed by the late Milos
Forman traces the story of Wolfgang
Amadeus Mozart through the eyes of his
greatest adversary Antonio Salieri at
least Salieri thinks he is Mozart's
greatest adversary the film is based on
Peter Schaffer's stage play and stars
Thomas Holtz as Mozart and F Murray
Abraham
it's a unique and very unstuff e
portrayal of a classical musical legend
who many consider to be the greatest
composer ever halts portrays him as a
giggling ambitious manchild who's never
fully grown up and is constantly being
saved from true disaster because of his
abilities in the end though the
pressures from his domineering stage dad
his wife Constance and her desperate
family and the manipulations of Salieri
conspire in the film to eventually break
Mozart and lead to a tragic ending along
the way however Foreman treats us to an
incredible unique biopic that delivers a
new appreciation of the man's music and
Abraham treats us to a delightfully and
frightfully unsettling portrayal of one
of the most unique villains in film
history and finally walking confidently
into our number one spot with a guitar
slung over its shoulder is James
Mangold's walk the line the film stars
Joaquin Phoenix is the legendary Johnny
Cash and Reese Witherspoon in an
oscar-winning turn as June Carter the
film vacillates between present day and
flashbacks as we see Cash's journey from
dirt poor cotton farmer to fledgling
musician to troubled famous musician to
legendary and beloved superstar the
driving force of this film however is
Cash's all-consuming love of
Witherspoon's Carter he destroys his
first marriage and almost his career
because of it and leaves a trail of
emotional wreckage in his wake and
within himself Reese Witherspoon is a
combination of heart and steel as she
resists fully giving into a love for
cash because of his responsibilities and
eventually his alcohol and drug
addiction this frustration and the guilt
over his brother's death leads cash to
an alcohol and drug field suicidal
depression that almost consumes him he
eventually confronts his past and his
pain in climbs out of his depression to
become the man in black and win the
heart of June it's definitely a
foot-stomping take-no-prisoners film
that features performances from two of
the greatest actors working today and a
director that would eventually direct
one of the best superhero films ever
made in Logan well there you have it
that's our top 5 music biopics in honor
of the release of Bohemian Rhapsody let
us know what you thought of this list
and what movies you would have included
on our list in the comments section
below remember to like and share this
video on your social media and subscribe
to our client a quick channel for more
videos just like this now go see
Bohemian Rhapsody in theaters and let it
rock you or you are no I'd even try to
turn the pie because your mud I walk the
line
[Music]